صيدليات مغلقه ورفوف ادويه شبه فارغه هذه
حصيله نحو اسبوعين من الاشتباكات يضاف لها
عمليات نهب واسعه طالت صيدليات ومخازن
ادويه في العاصمه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
ام درمان يستمر اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في ظل
تحذيرات من تفاقم الازمه الصحيه على مستوى
البلاد علينا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي او
الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
ديل الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في
الحايل الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفر في
الظروف العاديه فيها شح والان المشكله بقت
اكبر تهدد الازمه الحاليه صحه الكبار
والصغار على حد سواء فاسعار الادويه
بارتفاع مستمر فيما اصنافها المتوفره
بانخفاض مقلق وجد الاحداث الدوحه من سليم
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها تفتشوا ما خلى
اي حته فتش عشان القليب
واسعه ما خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا
حتى ما لقينا وحتى عربيه ذاته يتحركوا بها
عشان يجيبوا لي الدواء ما في بنزين ما في
هناك طريقه نمرق من البلد عشان نمشي نفتش
الدواء نجيبه اما بالنسبه للمستشفيات فلا
يزال القليل منها الذي يعمل في الخرطوم
يعاني نقصا حادا في الادويه والمستلزمات
العلاجيه الاخرى خاصه المتعلقه
بالجرحى والمحاليل الوريديه ما يفاقم من
معاناه المرضى مع استمرار توقف الامداد
الدوائي الحكومي نور الحصني العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات